hello and welcome to a very special
unboxing I rather large unboxing
wouldn't you say Mike mom would in
overwatch it's a video game a lot of us
been playing it in beta for a while
quite a long time yes it's actually on
open beta right now so you can go play
yourself regardless of if you
pre-ordered it or not this is a 129 $99
version of it it is the collector's
edition you can also get the origins
edition which is just 60 bucks it's
basically the game and a couple of extra
skins for people who got it early but
this one obviously big asking price so
it's kind of a bunch more stuff so I
guess the question we want to answer
today is is it worth it so let's let's
open this bad boy microwave this is how
do you think it opens Siri by it's a
weird no idea what is this diagonal line
stickers off with on sheath ish comes in
a piece of cardboards and then this is
the rest comes out here to be honest
this part of the box can be used as a
famine of sorts let's go to sweet you
can put your cat in it they can kind of
make like a playhouse look ahead it just
box itself is pretty sweet
whoa is it oh it opens okay this is
interesting thinking should we try and
get the big reveal so doors that and
it's got soldier 76 in it so I guess we
should probably open this part first
this is the meat and potatoes of the
yeah 130 dollar action interesting
choice
soldier 76 MOT muscle assay consider one
of the main like I don't play him much I
guess I guess he is one of the main
characters yeah but say he's one of the
least over watching characters yes and
he's very Call of Duty ish yes when I
was talking to the developers he was
basically created because they wanted to
have somebody who call of duty and halo
players people say it's kind of the
entry point yeah he's got a gun I mean
the detail in the hair and stuff is
really good okay let's see what else is
in here and this in life is a nicely
packaged Fox okay next one a visual
source book it's a nice sort of sleeve
on it there
and that's basically basically in our
book I would say there's some text on
here as well
backstory of ex uh the ominous and the
war and whatnot it's actually quite a
lot of here and then back starting all
of the characters okay so I think
judging by that paragraph I just read
about bashing really quickly I think
it's the same back sure they have on the
website which okay delve into a little
bit so it's a little bit of oak like
story abilities pages and stuff the
concept art and what not it's kinda cool
smells good - yeah yeah book alright
parchment first day of school what else
we got here we got the same track it's
got one two three four five spent twelve
songs on it probably just menu music and
a bunch of other songs you're aware this
is very kind of available on YouTube
already but maybe it's got a color back
there you go and then the most important
part of them all here we have the game
on a DVD Wow a digitally versatile disc
yeah it's got a code on us which we will
be covering in the b-roll
ahem it's got the Widowmaker and waar
skin as well which comes with this
version of the game so the other things
you get with this is that you know
there's would love to do this with the
games any other of their IPs they sort
of throw in some some of the freebies so
there's a Starcraft 2 guest pass there
is a world of warcraft guest pass
there's also a bunch of heroes of the
storm stuff there's a free hero here but
they also have a bunch of extra stuff
like overwatch only things you also get
a baby winston pest for world of
warcraft there is a tracer hero three
heroes of the storm at the habló 3 mercy
wings hearthstone cards sort of cecht
like the back of it and some ingame
portraits for Starcraft 2 and of course
the the noir skin we already talked
about it and then last but certainly not
least
or maybe least I don't know depends on
often you send a postcard I guess I've
got some postcards for all the different
maps Dorado
ha Nomura Hollywood Elias King's row
yeah all the maps and that's it the
overwatch collector's edition 129 99
it's available for
you see Xbox one and the PlayStation 4
Mike what do you think hundred thirty
bucks worth the asking price yeah if
you're super excited for overwatch I'd
say it is
I mean it's good-looking statue for me
that's the only thing is that I wish
this was somebody else I think
personally I love Airy looking forward
to the game and I've been playing the
beta osh obviously put up those videos
as well I'm GameSpot sort of diving into
the backstory of it so it's a game that
I've I've been sort of interested in for
a long time but for 130 bucks I think it
for me I'm not sure if 76 is that's the
only thing that kind of sticks out to me
is maybe not the one for me he's
definitely not one of the characters I
get excited about when I think about
going I like basically never play so but
yeah maybe you do let us know in the
comments what do you think this is worth
it over watch out the couple of weeks
time on the 24th of this month for
PlayStation 4 Xbox one and PC 60 bucks
if you don't spend all this dosh
you